but my name is beyond bad welcome back
to ism are happy with us we're gonna
stop I have never and I like an idea
what the hell I'm doing uh how about a
ten that sounds fun can talk hey we
gotta get a ten you like a Thursday but
I love to eat [ __ ] no you don't you
like dicks but I loved it what dad -
[ __ ] my touchin him I stopped being
scared of everything Jesus guys we're
going in the crocodile well yeah that's
[ __ ] urine in his mouth
casting whoa be careful nerd I am
careful but I don't care
alright here we go go back to the errand
why the hell it oh hi we're alive did we
just went out his [ __ ] not even
notice that's awesome
hey we're on grass now don't care shut
up thank you
I'm sorry my god it's like what the [ __ ]
am I talking about
okay dad just be careful stop [ __ ] up
here whoa whoa go go die yes a minute
I'm gonna kill you [ __ ]
duh dude I'm already dead though that's
what you get
wasn't that point I'll see you in a
second
whoa I'm a [ __ ] giraffe now age an
animated of cars you didn t hey totally
knit well dad that was awesome what it
was double awesome what that was crap
are you okay son actually I don't care
okay
whoa slap but I'm slapping your butt
downside my butt oh yeah oh yeah they
upheld up here come on come on [ __ ]
[ __ ] up I slap your butt stop [ __ ] no no
way am I going here the hell is going on
I'm touching your body
to give you but stop touching it I swear
to god man or letter [ __ ] boy yeah
yeah yeah stop being pumped and
wrestling why not
I want bowed and so pissed off what but
what the [ __ ] was that someone tell me I
what hey forget give me that [ __ ] out
all right just a regular dating where my
sandwich I'm so distraught what the hell
are you doing in there y'all [ __ ]
care for cancer the hell is the point of
this ah tape roll flip my you're a girl
for there you [ __ ] [ __ ]
no no aah come here come here I'll kill
ya
I got your leg I ate it no don't eat my
leg oh I'll eat [ __ ] twice Oh son of a
[ __ ] I'm so so passed table flip I want
to do it [ __ ] table ah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you disrupted me what are you is
that a helmet or an apple I don't even
care come here [ __ ] and grab your there
we go
nom nom nom I'll eat your dick out here
Oh down the hole
Oh watermelons we're rich buddy I'm so
happy I'll kiss this chain mwah mwah
mwah I'll do it all night long' rope
swing with Timmy that sounds awesome
dad I'm gonna do dish for you huh
oh yeah - what am i doing chicken - yeah
finger [ __ ] wait you had the play you
have to press ctrl uh-huh Oh
dad please don't leave me oh don't care
ah I'm alive how much America huh okay
okay okay okay
don't move now move in
Oh circle uh it's horrible okay focus
photo guys yes
son of a [ __ ] huh okay okay
I'm scared are you okay son come on I
want to finish this thing let me go
stupid [ __ ] no way okay let's go
[ __ ] come on piece of [ __ ] son that face
Oh watch me guy your piss okay Oh die
alright there we go
yeah [ __ ] you died instantly alright
there we go
uh-huh yeah yeah ah [ __ ] it I promised
myself I would try to finish maps but I
guess I promised you bros but here we go
ye try hard to face come on ah I did not
expect that
hey the leg mated come on come on you
little [ __ ] do it you don't have a how
many times I have to tell you to shut up
you then collect the car in your piece
of [ __ ] okay
click the coin what backflip come on
come on a key I can do it huh huh super
Springs okay MA huh come on man [ __ ]
dick vomit isn't what oh [ __ ]
good monkey arm - I can't do it slide oh
I do this piggies laughs oh yeah well
tape remote activate hey Sonic
of having a big butt yeah yeah all right
not getting an erection
I again why would I come on man you can
dab it whoa hi hi there mrs. uh mom can
you survive I know but I can't survive
slowly don't really like this but let's
do it anyway yeah yeah [ __ ] love this
actually no I hate if you Deb if I dad
really really fine whatever let's just
wow my arms oh yes
[ __ ] god let's go really fast but in
a sec holy [ __ ] man
of course that is a regular regular day
what else the bag at full don't move har
like what the pie it said food fiber
whoa look what de Lappe take away your
legs wha that's what you get for it
okay well is that big owe you [ __ ]
yeah don't move harpoon play this bit
about what I did I did it I played it
your work down your Africa I played your
Mac like thanks for making it I'm sorry
it's not like an [ __ ]
another responsible dad alright
I don't trust if you go first on that I
won't huh Oh Jennifer Bob no right yeah
okay I'm going down hey wait a minute
I don't goddamn it I'm coming to take
the watermelon what catch my watermelon
bridge goddamn it
can't even all right it's tied again
talk dad watch a melon there we go
[ __ ] off look Superman ah
I came to save your dad
Oh backflip stop don't throw things my
mouth you [ __ ]
I would go again Malu from the end okay
[ __ ] the watermelon there we go sorry by
that I sorry about your peanut man Oh
backwards huh we made it huh
sorry about that man slow Pogo one I
don't oh no no no okay
die pick a fine watch ha don't tell me
watch oh [ __ ] me
whoa I'm dead okay I don't care you
don't have to tell me [ __ ] what a hell
is it I'm just gonna show you here fine
I'm supposed to go up here that's why
yeah yeah bounce bounce baby
dundun dundun dundun let's sneak up on
this [ __ ] die oops
ah there we go hey where'd it go whoops
started by that man sorry sorry it
happened everyone soon
what sorry about your party this is your
woman God care Milo you sound like a
woman
alright here we go backflip double
backflip oh whoa whoa whoa
ah yeah that's add [ __ ] naylet now
we're gonna kiss my bike
Tony I can't reach it alright let's
finish with Superman race where there is
possible dad [ __ ] you Santa [ __ ] care
Oh No
hey comet Michi are you all right whoa
I'm in the lead bitchin oh I got an axe
I can [ __ ] chopper oh no I got Rick
at least I have a pineapple nom nom nom
nom nom nom
oh hey Alex who lives in a pineapple
under the sea
I got you Santa I'm riding Santa [ __ ]
tag that [ __ ] Santa can't get her her
hey watch out whoa nice Dodge Santa I'm
humping [ __ ] ya shout are we doing this
[ __ ] you sad I'm doing it alone with
pineapple [ __ ] yeah best winning pose
ever okay I think that would be enough
for today bruh
hey call of duty anybody like a vision
guys just gotta come Britney now see you
next episode that's pretty much it haha
say awesome right
yes we'll kill you wait is he coming
back
why is it coming back